I don't particularly have a disagreement
if someone wants to campaign on trans
rights it seems to me what stone wants
to campaign on it I have an issue with
the way in which it chose to campaign
but if you're going to build a strategy
around trans rights you have to find a
way of engaging with some of the
difficulties that it poses
[Music]
hello and welcome to martial matters of
me Winston Marshall at The Spectator in
London today I am joined by Perrier
award-winning comedian author of the
book The Power of difference writer
broadcaster a co-founder of the gay
rights charity Stonewall and also a
co-founder of the new company diversity
by Design Simon Fanshawe Simon thank you
so much for taking the time to speak
with me today that's a real pleasure
um so I have to say we don't know that
we'll see we'll see you might dislike it
they'll be the judge of that
quite um I'm sure it will be a pleasure
for me um and it's been a pleasure
actually looking into your astounding
life and
um the many things you you've done and
been up to and are still up to and I
hope we can dig into that um uh I I'd
love to ask it we'll start with
um the formation of Stonewall
um so you're one of the six co-founders
how did that come about well it's always
funny having one's introduction read
because the truth of it is I've never
been able to hold down a job I mean
that's the truth in fact I've never had
a job so you know it's kind of desperate
uh catalog of failure really in
198789 there was a piece of legislation
which was originally dreamed up by
somebody a couple of people on the on
the sort of further right of the
conservative party so remember this is
Thatcher's a conservative government
Margaret Thatcher's conservative
government but it was adopted by the
government and it was part of a local
government bill it was known as section
28 it actually started section 22 I
think and then it became like a bingo
call it sort of changed its name 22 24
25 you know all the eights and then
what it was
it was the Prohibition
of uh of of promoting homosexuality as a
pretended family relationship there's a
very bizarre kind of um pretended
pretended family relationship
the context was the left authorities uh
what were known as The Looney left
authorities by the Sun and such like in
particularly London but not exclusively
so we're talking Brent haringay you know
uh Hackney and so on and so forth and
the GLC and they had become great
Advocates of kind of lesbian and gay
rights and they had gone out of their
way to help you know kids at school and
kids in college and so on so people
growing up to understand that you know
there was all sorts of possibilities in
life and they hadn't necessarily done it
well but they'd done it and and what
section 28 was I think was a really good
way of bashing the so-called loony left
authorities the thing I might ask guys
is we're terribly useful as a political
weapon because if you want to look
fabulous and liberal you know you just
have to have gay friends you know and
all your kids have gay godparents you
know anybody lesbian Auntie no one talks
to you you know in the playgrounds of
North London and so on
so we're very useful and if you're on
the right we're also very useful because
we're a really good dog whistle so you
blow the dog whistle people are teaching
your children to be gay you know and all
that so we're very useful on both sides
of the political spectrum and we are
used a lot on both sides of the
political Spectrum so I think if you
look at that period what section 28 was
really about as I say it was a weapon to
beat the Looney left authorities there
were cancers in Brighton where I live
going around saying they're not painting
your front door on the council house
because they're funding this gay pride
you know
we took on the challenge though because
clearly what it was the effect of it was
to stigmatize us now what you have to
remember too think back to the 80s or
look at the history of the agency if
you're too young to have lived through
it so the first a person who died of
AIDS in Britain died in 81 or 82. the
Terence Higgins trust was formed during
a few years later so you've got the 80s
a book ended
by the AIDS crisis and then by section
28 so it was a decade in which we were
fighting the stigma and and the
stigmatization of our lives and so it
was difficult not to say we didn't party
and Dance I mean you know people in
South Africa are even there you know
they slap money to Boots and dranks and
booze see a party while you're having a
bad time but it was a really really
pressured politically pressured time and
after the the sort of great flowering of
things once we were legal or once we
were not illegal in 1967. see all we've
got is visibility so once that's my
coming out it's kind of important so
once you're out you know then you're in
the street you can't be arrested just
for being in the street so what happened
was everything flowered I mean they were
getting sailing clubs yachting clubs
political clubs all that sort of stuff
so the 80s came and that stuff
solidified into firstly work around AIDS
and buddying and pressuring and getting
Health Services to take it seriously and
then at the end of the 80s section 28
came those networks were there and they
sprung into action but what was
interesting was that we took it on not
as a subject about gays but we took it
on as a free speech issue so we said if
you stigmatize if you prohibit
homosexuality and talking about
homosexuality in schools what you will
do is you will empty the libraries you
will deprive kids of the full penalty of
you know culture and arts and so on and
so forth and actually while we lost the
battle because it went on to the statute
book what we realized was that whatever
people think about homosexuality in
Britain
they still want people to be treated
fairly and that understanding was really
important and so Stonewall came out of
that with the simple slogan which was we
want equality under the law so that was
how it started with a very very simple
message and it is quite interesting that
all the advances around lesbian and gay
rights have been made in Britain by not
talking about homosexuality in other
words if you ask people whether they've
got to view about whether it's right or
wrong actually some people will just go
it's wrong but interestingly some of
those same people will also acknowledge
that you don't want to stigmatize people
under the law
as a group so you can win them over to
that position and that was really
important understanding that I certainly
took away from those years in Stonewall
and then so in the years after that by
the way there are some things that are
immediately coming to mind about how
it's not necessarily homosexuality but
the transgender issue that sort of
replaced that but maybe we'll come to
that okay before that um uh in the years
after that so through the the 90s the
stone will continue to do great things
uh extending adoption and IVF rights and
and civil partnership I guess it would
culminated in the silver partnership uh
it was that 2004 and and so um
uh and then after
2004 what when did you leave Stonewall
was it well I was on the board until I
can't remember but probably something
like about 94 or 95 so we started 89 and
I was probably on the board for six
years or something like that you know
it's a standard term and then you know
you pass it on to other people because
that's what you do you know you give it
to them you say you kind of crack on
with it and build it and what happened
up to 97 which was the labor government
was that we constantly fought the age of
consent battle and we constantly lost
so I have a very you know a very maoist
slogan for that which is you know every
defeat was a victory and the reason I
say that was that every time we were
defeated in Parliament around the equal
age of consent we won public support for
the notion of equality so we continue to
build this public support So when labor
came in committed to equal rights for
lesbians and gays notwithstanding some
nervousness about that we were able to
persuade them that actually this is a
pretty popular stance actually pretty
much everybody's got a gay friend or a
nephew or a son or a child of themselves
and actually pretty much everybody
doesn't think that it's okay to treat
gays differently from themselves what
was the age of consent well it was well
it's interesting
um was it lowered or raised in the
Victorian era the answer was it was
lowered so what we what happened was
that then it got raised uh and then
eventually it was illegal
you know and then it was 21 when uh in
1967 so when when homosexuality was
decriminalized it was decriminalized on
condition of both men because women
weren't included in the legislation at
all men were both consenting
over adult consenting there were over 21
and they were in private and hotel rooms
for instance were regarded as not
private and and heterosexual relations
what was it 16. oh I see so and what
year did that well it came down it there
was a compromise at 18 and then it
finally came to 16 uh sometime after 97
can't remember exactly when so you were
still very thinking very favorably of
Stonewall through that period and we're
still supporting the organization well
what was important about it was as I say
it was building these big these big
broad alliances of public opinion so if
you think for instance about um
the question should gay people be
parents
so that's a question that some
particularly on the sort of religious
right would ask you know gay people
should not be parents you know parents
kids need you know a boy and a man and a
woman you know unique well okay but
there's a more interesting question
which is as a society how do we make
sure that children are brought up in the
best possible circumstances and with the
best possible conditions for success in
their future life now that's a much
better question and once you take the
Prejudice out of the question then you
have to say well actually it turns out
that some heterosexual parents are
really good and some are terrible and
actually some gay parents are good and
some are terrible Stone will never said
we have a right to be parents they said
we want an option to be parents so what
I'm saying to you is we always built
that much wider constituency I think by
asking bigger questions so with the
military you know there's always this
thing about um you know there was a ban
on having gays in the armed forces
and it was quite funny I come from an
army background my dad was uh an officer
in the argyle in Southern Highland he's
a lifelong Soldier and um so I'm quite
used to these barking gents oh hello you
know those sorts of people you know and
they just they literally bark at you
it's like being a menagerie and they've
got wives that squawk so yeah he's going
and she's going real real you know it's
completely peculiar and anyways I've
grown up with these people I am these
people and um so I found myself in a
studio once with a with a barking
General and he he would say they always
say they always say homosexual which I
always loved very very upper class she
said and that's it you know it's about
about gays in the Army and he was saying
he said well obviously
I can't have you know homosexuals in the
Army because uh if one is in the shower
with a non-normal heterosexual
non-airisexual desire and as a
homosexual uh
homosexual well um yeah we'll be very
very nervous
and I remember saying to this channel I
said to be perfectly honest
if a gay guy thinking you've got a cute
ass makes you scared then I don't think
the Army's the right job for you
you're really in the wrong career love
you know so we thought but the point
about it well seriously the point about
about gays in the Army is that you know
Defending Your Country is a great
sign of citizenship I mean it's you know
some you know marriage and Defending
Your Country knows and voting these are
major moments of citizenship and so the
idea that you say actually what are the
qualities we want in ourselves or a
sailor or an air person what are the
qualities we want to defend our country
that is a more interesting question than
whether they're gay and absolutely
there's a rule in the armed forces that
you don't have sex with other members of
your troop and platoon and whatever they
call them in the Air Force in the Navy
so the no sex rule that's fine yeah do
you see what I mean so what is what do
you want what are the qualities you
wanted a person to defend the country
what relationship does that have to
sexual orientation and as we see now
when you've got both women on active
service and also lesbians engaged in the
Army actually it's it's no lesser
effective fighting force so we were
always raising those bigger questions so
my point is that what I learned from
Stonewall was that you can make
alliances with people without demanding
total agreement and actually if you
think of relationships that's how that's
how we work that's how marriages work
how any relationship Works in any
relationship how can you Benjamin
Franklin said is everyone if everyone's
thinking the same that no one's thinking
like you how can you possibly act in the
world if you're not collaborating with
people who think slightly differently
absolutely and there is a style of
politics that demands the sort of total
agreement and it's not new I mean I
remember being uh involved in Brighton
where I lived which is there was a big a
tradition of the national front in
Brighton and the British national party
John tendall I think lived there for a
while that kind of thing he was one of
the leaders
um and there was a thing called the
anti-naz elite you may remember you know
and there was fabulous concerts and you
know Tom Robinson you know Susie and the
Banshees and all this stuff and we also
sort of Hackney marshes didn't we you
know what you had to touch a balloon to
your friends so you knew where they were
that's what I always remember anyway so
fantastic anti-nazi league and I
remember going to an anti-nazi League
meeting in Brighton
and uh this was kind of some years in
and the swp which was the Socialist
Workers Party which I think was called
is in those days but International
Associates but they demanded that the
anti-nazi league took a position on
Britain's membership of NATO
um sorry I thought we were here no fun
equals you know no the NF equals no fun
I thought we're fighting the fascist I
didn't think we're wearing a seminar on
geopolitical relationships in Britain's
role you know in common defense Etc
Collective defense organizations so I
left but that kind of politics is very
prevalent and I'm sure it's prevalent to
the right I've never been on the right
so I don't know but it's very prevalent
and always has been prevalent on the
left is that there's a sense of total
agreement on a platform otherwise we
will exclude you and you see I mean it's
an endless theme and it's very very
strong at the moment but it's not new
well it's there's I mean presumably the
word for it is authoritarian because if
you're in the concept of democracy is
that it is authoritarian I also think
that it's got its roots in some sort of
some sense of belonging I think that
there's some idea that I think people
you know we get a great deal of of
Comfort out of tribalism and it's one of
the things I wrote this book The Power
of difference and it is there is an odd
contradiction in there because you do
have to share certain things to be able
to get on with people in order to
explore your differences so you do have
to share something and I think the
problem is that people then they they
they get very comforted by the idea that
actually we all agree about something
that is a comfortable position to be in
and you see it in all sorts of places I
mean let's not kid ourselves you know if
you're in a group of blokes and you're
sitting there and there's banter starts
and people start making jokes they think
is sexist it can be very difficult if
you're not of a certain kind of
personality say actually hang on chaps
actually I'm sorry I don't like that I
think that's offensive it's hard to step
out of your group so understand how it
happens because it's very reinforcing to
be around people who agree with you but
it doesn't help you to grow and
certainly I mean my Terror about growing
old is that I will turn into an
intolerant old fart
I mean God you know you know the young
people God that would be so awful and at
the moment that's trying my patience
because I'm getting there so you think
right now that there's more intolerance
to or
the uh more of a sense that one has to
be completely pure and agree with
everyone's everyone's opinions on
everything in able to politically
collaborate with people is that no I
think I'm saying that's always been
there I think that Purity that Purity
kind of idea is is strong and I think
you can see that you can certainly see
it in religion you know I mean the the
notion of the heretic is not a new one I
think at the moment there are things
that reinforce it and I mean obviously
I'm talking about social media so there
are people who there are ways of
demanding compliance that there weren't
before so if you step out of line as you
well know you've experience the pylon
that you experienced
was really only possible because of
social media it you would have had to
have been
excuse me this me saying this you would
have had to be an enormous star and the
papers would have need to take it on as
it happens you're incredibly talented
but you're not you know you're not Tina
Turner you know bless you but you know
and well tried and you know I know I
know maybe maybe on a Thursday night
maybe
baby you are simply the best I don't
know
but whatever
and what I'm saying is but social media
now actually enables that interaction
enables that that traction by a
relatively small group of people that
can create a lot of noise so I don't
think it's the Purity the notion of the
heretic that's new I think the no what's
new is the mechanisms well why don't you
tell me about your book and it's a
perfect segue perfect segue a perfect
bit of self-promotion the power of
inference the power of difference the
book starts actually saying why am I
writing this book
um because a very good friend of mine
very sweetly read it for me somebody I
went to University with she's fabulous
she she was at University we were at
Sussex University in the 70s so if I
describe Francis as having
um she's the only person I know who was
the women's officer in the students unit
in Sussex who also had Carmen rollers or
high heels and floaty dresses I mean
she's just she comes from a Quaker
background she's fiercely intelligent
very funny and and sort of
counter-intuitive in those days when in
order to be a feminist obviously you
have to wear clogs and dungarees and I
love her she's got a really s powerful
intelligence and she very sweetly read
the book
and she said to me something really
useful she said right so the thing about
this book is it's got intellectual
content and it's got references and all
that but it is not an academic book and
you don't want it to be treated as an
academic book so you need to situate it
personally so you need to reach you need
to write chapter zero brilliant piece of
advice because it made me think why do I
value difference
um
so I started off by thinking well I
think I value difference partly because
psychologically
growing up with my parents who fought
past ionately
all the way through their marriage
um
for control really it's about to say
anything else but at the same time
assuring me that they loved each other
and they loved me now not responding I
found it quite difficult sometimes I
didn't like it I found it it was an
adolescent I found it really just
difficult however
because I didn't always believe that
they did but I think they did although
you know like all couples maybe they
should have got divorced I mean the
famous Civil Thorndike quote she said
after being married I think it's you
casting on someone for years and years
and years somebody said to her you never
thought of divorce over six he said
divorce never said murder never divorce
so you know and my parents were like
that they were absolutely you know at
each other as well but they adored each
other in a way
um and they battled for control I think
I've grown up with what I subsequently
discovered at Sussex of course is what
Marx is called dialectic you know which
is obviously opposing views creating a
synthesis so I really value different
psychologically a value difference I
value arguments I've grown up as that's
part of my psychological pattern I know
that secondly I went from
you know Army I said my my father was in
the army
as I said a serving officer you know we
were classic you know my dad was in a
Scottish regiment it's kind of classic
Anglo Scott officer blah blah you know
so where I hung around as a kid you know
people have very middle class which
always annoys me because I'm upper
and middle class and you know I mean I'm
Posh and so I went to Sussex and
certainly there there I am I'm meeting
people who are completely different from
me in Social background and beaten
viciously about the heads by feminists
intellectually saying well what kind of
man are you and it's amazing that period
of my life was such a gift
because it suddenly put me in a position
where I really had to think about who I
was but without
I mean lots of other people you know
what ideas I put on the cravat whereas
they drop the H's you know what I mean
it was that sort of thing so I was kind
of wearing gravatt for the miners and
they were all kind of wearing donkey
jackets so I kind of kept that bit and I
sort of played that up a bit but I was
made wonderfully aware of of of the
excitement of difference so that's
another really important moment and I do
think the thing about being gay isn't
that chubby interesting about being gay
it's just that you know you are
I mean you know I mean it's just a thing
you know
um but it does put you in an interesting
relationship to the rest of the world as
you go up because and you see it with
with with people who are gay whose
parents are very liberal they still have
to go through that Readjustment and it's
a psychological Readjustment you're
readjusting your expectations of life
and your your assumptions about who
you're going to be you're having to
reorganize them and that gives you a
certain distance from from from from the
society grew up in so I'm always you
know I can play sort of Posh white boy
but I also I'm 20 always slightly
outside so I play an in and out game and
I think being an outsider in that way
very slightly
and I'm not this is not special pleading
it's just trying to explain what I felt
I think that gives you a real sense of
difference and the enjoyment of
difference so you're a different kind of
man you have lots in common with men but
you're also different from them so all
those things mean that I enjoy a
difference in a way that you know the
human condition is that you can't
understand somebody else you can't walk
in their shoes you can't experience life
as they experience life what you can do
is try but only in the certain knowledge
that you never will get there and it's
that Journey it's diversity that's why
we talk about diversity inclusion
because we're different we don't talk
about it because we want to make
everybody the same we so my view is we
want to talk about it because we want to
explore and experience and enjoy the
difference okay so so what obviously
strikes stands out and and you must this
must be done intentionally I think is
that we're talking about diversity
equity and inclusion essentially without
mentioning identity entity because it's
all this is essentially sort of division
of labor skill set everyone it is the
best position for for their individuals
skills and this is in the face of the
popular
anti-individual philosophy of the age
I.E identitarianism yourself well that's
right I mean but well it is are you are
you arguing against that specifically no
I'm arguing for for an understanding
that gives us both an understanding of
what might be the group experience but
being really accurate about what the
group experience is and then
understanding what the individual
ambition and aspiration and and journey
so what we have to do with people which
when you say group though right well let
me explain so when so classically in the
diversity world people talk about you
know Bain for instance that's a phrase
that people use black and minority
ethnic
well what you have to think if you're
going to use any category in life to
describe and analyze something you need
to know what it's describing now if you
think of the people who would broadly be
included in this category of Bame
are they United by culture ethnicity
religion family structure geographical
Heritage no political views no it's a
vast group one thing it can describe is
the experience of not being white in
Britain very seldom is Bain by the way
used to include Jewish people in
Brighton where I live the council has
explicitly excluded anti-Semitism I
understand from their definition of
racism so that's been a big battle so
Bain really describes one experience and
it's the experience it describes is the
experience of being
not white in the majority white country
so broadly speaking now there is a set
of common experiences
there are a set of common experiences of
grammatical error there as a waste of
public school money and there are a set
of assessive of of experiences that
those people will share in common and
there's no doubt about it you know when
you meet other gay people there is a
certain shared experience so I once
wrote a piece called um the end of the
homosexual was it just a phase we were
going through
and uh then I wrote a draft and then I
had a bunch of gay friends to dinner and
we all screamed and shouted and and I
thought this is really weird I've just
written a bad game and I've got nothing
in common actually I've suddenly just
experienced that we've got something in
common so there is a common experience
and that is important and so back to my
belonging back to the tribe quests and
all that so we we experience blood and
it's important when you analyze so you
can take data of our company and you can
say where are women in up and across
this company who's being recruited who's
being promoted who's being deployed and
you can work out where that is and you
can see that very often in companies
there's a ceiling that women hit is this
right is this something your company is
doing yeah we we work with people on
this data my point is responding to your
point about identity
the point is that group of women have a
common experience and you could look at
the data and it can tell you what that
group experience is what it can't tell
you is what the individual experience of
that individual woman who's there in
front of you with her Ambitions her life
her desires and and what she wants to do
okay so so you've got to the point is
you've got to mix what
it's a job where it's actually being a
woman makes you more competent
at the job why why does it matter that
it's a woman doing it well because you
just want the most competent person to
do that well you don't want who cares
where they're from what sex is what
their sexuality is so what I say is
always it's not who you are it's what
you bring through who you are so as an
individual you bring a story my story of
sketch bits of it so my story is about
difference growing up portions of
entering you know a place where I
discovered all these other social
classes and I discovered feminism so
there's a whole bunch of stuff that I
bring as a gay man I bring an outsider
attitude as a gay man
I'm not saying so individual women bring
a particular story and women as a group
bring a particular story so and it this
matters in two ways it matters because
if you look at the data the data will
tell you that women experience
particular barriers to advancement in
certain organizations they just do the
data tells that it's very very clear
okay now why that happens then has to be
really thought about in detail so we
have to understand what's going on there
but the other thing which is interesting
is this so about 18 months ago the
Harvard Business Review did a a piece of
research on risk and they were looking
at the metric they used was to look at
executive teams
and they said right growth strategies
the growth strategies are of two broad
kinds endogenous growth which is you
know growth through uh research
Innovation investment and there's
mergers and acquisition
the lattice strategy is a much higher
risk strategy than the endogenous
strategy
what they then did was they looked at
teams that had a balance of men and
women and teams that were mostly men and
they looked at what strategies they
favored
and interestingly they favored the
higher risk strategy and when they went
down to look and I'll try and work out
why that was the case they discovered
something about women in companies and
it's this
as you go up a company as a bloke if you
try something
and it doesn't work the culture of the
companies tends to say well he had a go
if you're a woman and you try something
that doesn't work company cultures tend
to say she can't do it
so as women progress up organizations
they start to calibrate risk differently
because it has a higher Jeopardy for
them so when you put men and women at a
senior level in an organization to
discuss risk you actually get a much
richer approach to the discussion of of
risk
similarly we were once asked to help an
organ an English literature Department
in a university diversify their
recruitment of staff and I looked at
their data and I said to the person
running about what probably trying to
sell this great Department it's all
going gangbusters and this person said
something really interesting she said
there's great English literature being
written in the world at the moment by
people who are not English
she said so what I want to do I want to
reflect that aspect of the Canon the
modern Canon of English literature in
the staff it would look like ethnic
diversity it wasn't ethnic diversity she
wanted it was cultural and Geographic
diversity she wanted to bring into the
curriculum the research and
understanding of the great literature
that's been written in the Caribbean in
India in in Kenya in Nigeria so she was
enriching so the whole thing was about
enriching the research and the
curriculum the whole point about the
risk strategy is that there's an actual
benefit to the organization by having a
richer and better debate so my book is
about what happens when you combine
those differences both individual
personal style wise but also actually
people do bring group differences which
might reflect culture or lifestyle or
class or their sex or whatever each of
those things brings a story Into the
organization and you have to see both of
those things so white people often say
to me it's always white people say this
they say oh well I I don't I don't see
race I just treat everybody as you know
as an individual and I always say the
same thing to them I say if you don't
see race you're missing out on something
but if you only see race you're also
missing out on something okay so what I
I've was been disturbing me a little bit
about the recent Dei movement is that
we're spending a lot in Britain we're
spending a lot of money so the NHS
spends 40 million a year on diversity
offices Civil Service Apparently one
million days a year away certain
equality and diversity and training 120
million pounds a year is spent on uh
diversity training the public sector
employs ten thousand staff to deal with
EDI and costs taxpayer 427 million
pounds a year is what you're talking
about a way of
doing that constructively or is it a
separate because the the Dei stuff is
very much about identity it's about it's
not about practical stuff at all it's
about having take quotas of different
ethnic groups of sexualities of having
trans and all of that represented and
that's the objective get those people in
and it's costing us hundreds of millions
so is is this related so yeah it is but
what what I'm I'm a bit of a diversity
dissident in the sense that what I'm
trying to do is to help people have more
effective conversations hence my
division for instance into
deficits and dividends you need to know
what you're doing in an organization you
need to know what you're doing and
whether or not the combination of people
you're recruiting and I wouldn't say see
one of the one of the flaws of this is I
don't think it is the best person for
the job I think it's the best team for
the job because most jobs are done in
collaboration with other people there's
very few jobs except perhaps a pure
mathematician that's just done on their
own we all we all work in teams so the
key thing is what's to understand what
the combination is the back to my
English literature Department that
person knew what combination she wanted
to enrich the curriculum and the
research and that's the core purpose of
what she was trying to do so she knew
that so A lot of times I think that what
happens is that things are being done as
they are done in lots and lots of places
not just around diversity there are a
series of processes so now what's
happened is uh so people say well we're
going to do we're going to do diversity
so what are we going to do we're going
to reverse mentoring we can do
unconscious biased training so sort of
you know there's a supermarket basket
you know you bang it in go to the till
and that'll do
my Approach is to say our approach is to
say hang on a sound before you do any of
that
the first thing we need to understand is
why are you doing this
so the reasons might be you know
widespread we work with an NHS trust for
instance
that is the biggest employer in the
region in which it sits I won't say
which it is but there are two big motor
manufacturers in the region they're
still the biggest employer
part of their their desire was to be the
most attractive employer in the region
really to manage to appeal across the
demographics of the region
so that's an important thing for them to
do partly because they're a public
service but basically they want to offer
opportunities to the widest range of the
public because they're a public service
they also want then to say What's the
best way of developing the best
healthcare services for the region now
often people say and I will give this
example because I'm sure they won't mind
but we won't work with Yorkshire
ambulance terrific
and one of the things that obviously an
ambulance service or a Health Service
like that might say is we want to be
representative of the population we
serve great aspiration
but not possible I said to them okay
close your eyes this is the board next I
said close your eyes and think about
Yorkshire let's think about Leeds in
Bradford
now I think about nesborough harrogant
now I think about scar but now think
about York you can't represent York
Yorkshire I mean it's just sort of not
going to be possible and in your call
center the fact that you know the gay
Muslim is not going to ring up when the
gay Muslim happens you know it's that's
not gonna happen what you can do
is you can put together and learn from
each other
for instance say in the people who
designed the services a group that's got
sufficient difference in it
that alerts you to the difference
outside in the world
and the thing about homogenous groups is
they're less good at looking at it's
like a homogeneity of whatever kind by
the way they're less good at looking out
and my previous example people are less
likely to disagree in homogeneous groups
than they are in groups that are more
diverse there's a lot of research to
show that actually diversity
self-conscious recognition of difference
within a group helps you to alert
yourself to the differences that's like
now in an ambulance service it there is
lots of of data that tells you that
different groups of people use ambulance
services in different ways older younger
certain ethnic groups use ambulance and
a e more than they use GPS
etc etc etc women and men so there are
lots of differences out there about how
you make an ambulance service that
really does save people's lives in the
most effective way
so diversity plays a role in that but it
only plays a role in that if you're
really really rigorous about that
discussion in the way that I've tried to
lay it out so that seems to me like
perfectly reasonable because they're
going to be a better service if they
understand the community they're
involved in but let's say let's take a
football team
you the objective is to win you don't
need every member of your football team
to represent every Court let's say it's
Leeds United to Ever represent every
corner of Leeds mother certainly it is
international but but uh it's it's just
about winning this this concept is
specific to to different organizations
absolutely and so it's not relevant to
well it's relevant sometimes industry in
your business no that's absolutely right
but equally what you don't want is a
football team that doesn't have access
to talent because it won't employ black
players or actually at the moment it
won't it won't employ gay footballers
there might be tons of gay footballers
out there who just will not play
football and that's not a route that gay
men will ever take into football in
men's football because at the moment
it's too damn scary if you go out there
as a gay footballer you would be
barracked from the whatever we weren't
actually bright that's quite funny
eventually you think oh God's sake the
album come on but so you've got two
questions you've got two questions and I
think you're confusing the two questions
I go back to the dividend and the
deficit there is perfectly good there
are perfectly good reasons to solve
these deficits if people are having
blocks put in the way of their talent we
should be removing them if that often is
a result of the group they belong to we
know data tell us that women suffer in
terms of their Ambitions we know that
the data is very clear we know that
certain people experience rate back
people experience racism at work the day
so we've got to get to the root of this
and open up people's roots to their
ambition and stop the blocks of talent a
fully support stopping the blocks but
the response wouldn't then be that every
Premiership football team has to have at
least one gay film player on the team
have I said that no but that is what
that is the equivalent analogy for the
well that is part of the eye well it's
one of the problem ideology it's one of
the problems is that the mistake has
been to have a kind of a people call it
the tick box there's a sort of tick box
compliance and the easy way of doing
that is counting stuff and the easier it
accounts go okay well we look at census
and then everybody has to be
representative I don't take that view I
say that in different places you need a
different kind of combination of
difference and you also need to
understand whether the deficits that
you're experiencing your sector or your
company are particularly germane to the
ex to the functioning of the company or
what you're trying to do yeah so you've
got to do both that's my point you're
right in the diversity Orthodoxy often
people are not and that's why they
employ us because we do we have a I
think a more nuanced view of it and the
other thing you it's important to do is
that often these deficits and things
arise not because somebody's being
racist or sexist or homophobic their
rise for other reasons actually they
almost often they happen accidentally
that doesn't mean to say they're any
less awful for the person experiencing
them but if you're going to tackle them
you've got to understand what the
mechanism that's working
so can I take you back to Stonewall well
you're asking me never ask a question
the answer to which you don't want if
you want to take me back to Stonewood
I'm taking you back to Stonewall be the
dominatrix here for God's sake
Stonewall can you tell me what has
happened to Stonewall I know you're not
a part of the lgba now but it seems from
my research that you're a supporter I
might be wrong to correct if I'm wrong
but what happened
to Stonewall where it seems to have
there's been a great split where a lot
of people have left it a lot of people
from the gay rights movement supported
Stonewall for many years and now turned
against it what what's your uh Intel
your Insight so something extraordinary
happened between 1989 and 2014.
which was that we we and all the people
brilliantly who then took over from the
people who started it
uh we won
I mean with a few exceptions Northern
Ireland was a bit slow with the with the
Civil partnership the marriage thing
there's a bit of Pensions that need to
be sorted basically job done and we got
our equality woggle that's what I would
say we got our equality woggle job done
you know we've got the bag what's a
woggle it's a woggle you are you've got
no idea what you hear one of the
expectations it was that thing you put
on the you've had a scar for engineering
you had a woggle a woggle yeah and then
yeah for cooking and and things anyway
so back to Stonewall
so what happened 2014
legislative equality
issues social equality not saying that
people didn't experience violence or
whatever or harassment or unpleasantness
but I often say that even if it was an
everyday event it certainly was no
longer an all-day event so we'd
extraordinary success and at that point
the organization had a strategic pivot
as they call it in business
my own View and when they recruited the
new chief executive some three people I
know applied for the job and they all
rang me and said what do you think
Stonewall should do next I said well I
don't think that really matters but I'm
interested to know what you think
Stonewall should do next and all three
of them quite independently said the
same thing they said what Stonewall
should do now is devolve down to cities
and towns and the rural areas and build
the same alliances locally
as they were built nationally
so that when for instance that Rao set
up in the Birmingham schools a few years
ago which I write about in the book did
I say I've written a book it's called
The Power of difference frightfully
cheap it's Johnny good value for money
um
so in the Birmingham schools uh there
were there was a a a set of you know in
sort of personal social relationship
class or whatever it's called you know
they were teaching them and then there
was a bunch of Muslim parents who were
unhappy when is this uh it's about three
or four years ago four years ago
something like that
and there was a clash it was very
interesting actually because all the
Muslim Parent posters said things like
you know we are it was about parental
control over the content of the stuff
much more than actually whether or not
it was gay but anyway the point about it
was that sort of dispute Stonewall
wasn't on the ground in Birmingham in
the way that it would have on a national
level so what we were saying was at that
2014 moment gay marriage strategic pivot
what people were saying a lot of good
people were saying was Devils get down
now into the regions and the countryside
and so on and so forth and really built
affect people's lives so make sure that
what we've established the quality of
the national level is really getting
that sort of Attraction for people in
their everyday lives locally
they decided not to do that they just
pivoted and they and they pivoted
towards a national campaign
I differ from Matthew Paris on this
Matthew argues and he was one of the
other co-founders he argues that not one
of the original six one in the next law
and he argues that Stonewall shouldn't
got involved in the trans issue at all
my argument has always been that
actually what stonewalls should have
done was support those campaigns and
said as we always had done we did it
with the immigration group we did with
the Armed Forces Group we did with the
parents group in Stonewall we always
said we'll give you resources we'll give
you support get started but crucially
find your own voice
and then off you go you know out of the
nest fly because you saw them as as
different no because actually it's
important that people are involved in
that issue find their voice and they
find their way of campaigning and they
own it that's what's important about it
so you didn't see that issue as a
continuation of your of what Stonewall
had already done well I mean in the Army
and what do you mean the parents and all
you mean the immigration stuff and the
parents stuff and the army stuff yeah no
they were just they were groups who had
a common interest and they particularly
wanted to Major on that single campaign
and we were we were doing a much we were
doing a general campaign so the idea was
you you you you help them to find their
voice and then you back them as the
general and they are the specific so
it's just that it's just that if people
own a campaign it's really important
that sure they're in control of it you
know so I said always when people asked
well I think you know if you want to
campaign on trans rights or whatever
then they should take that campaign and
they should support Stone will support
it and then it should float off and it
should find its own voice
fortunately what happened was not that
what happened was
I don't particularly have a have a
disagreement if someone wants to
campaign on trans rights it seems to me
what stone wants to campaign on is
what's no one wants to campaign on if it
can get public support for what it
campaign's on well it should go off and
do that fine I have a I have an issue
with the way in which it chose to
campaign because what we had always done
as I explained before was built these
very Broad
alliances with people and crucially
around homosexuality and lesbians and
gays The crucial thing is actually
people have a view about homosexuality
and what you're not going to do is
change their view what you will do is
change the circumstances in which
lesbians and gays can live so the
crucial thing is to make a material
difference to the lives of the people
you're campaigning for and the way you
do that is to build these broad
alliances around bigger principles
so if what you're going to do and I
don't know what the right strategy would
have been but if you're going to build a
strategy around trans rights you have to
find a way of engaging with some of the
difficulties that it poses and that
self-id identity poses which is the idea
that you know you you get to be the
opposite sex or whatever and we know
that this raises significant issues
whatever you think about the various
views on it it is a simple fact that in
sport and in women's spaces and a
variety but there are issues because
there are differences of views and
opinions about the best way forward so
that what Stonewall should and could do
is to host that discussion they should
try and develop a platform which has got
the broadest support unfortunately what
they did was they decided to take this
idea which is equal what acceptance
without exception
unfortunately what that means is you end
up with a form of Purity politics you
end up saying that if you do not agree
with us on this issue then you are now
the heretic so myself and others became
the wrong kinds of gay because I think
that sex actually matters I think that
sex is immutable that doesn't mean to
say that I'm transphobic or something it
means to say that I think that trans
people have an extraordinary story to
tell but it's a different story to tell
a trans woman has a different story to
tell than a Than a Woman
and you know that's just to me the
richness and that's why I wrote a book
called The Power of difference rather
than the power of sameness
so my difficulty with Stonewall is that
it isn't building those broad alliances
that it needs to do it's trying to force
through
a set of legislative Alternatives which
frankly don't have the support of the
broad public whereas actually what we
drove through did have the support of
the broad public so that's my problem
with it and that's what I've said in
public and I think it's a shame because
we built a lot of credibility I remember
the first time the person who really did
this was a woman called Angela Mason who
was the chief exec of Stonewall she was
astonishing in building these alliances
I mean she's a really remarkable
politician if you like she she just has
the ability to understand and listen and
put together those different groups I
mean I have unbounded admiration for for
Angela
um and what they didn't do was that
they've they've pushed it to any and he
saw it recently in Scotland if you push
through a bad piece of legislation which
has too many holes in it and has is too
ambiguous
you end up losing the support of the
people is the problem then for Stonewall
if they're taking this on is that it's
actually an issue that you can't have
those broad conversations because the
issues say of uh we're talking about
impingement on women's spaces for
example
how do you how do you solve that issue I
mean you could have separate bathrooms
but if if what trans people what they
actually want is to be in the in a
woman's bathroom that's an and that's an
answer yes oh look when I say broad
Alliance I don't mean total agreement I
mean a broad Alliance there are going to
be people who end up disagreeing with
certain aspects of the policy that you
that you get but it seems to me that if
you think about these the the issue in
terms of three kind of categories if you
think about biology you think about
social interaction you think about law
and policy I think biology is pretty
settled I mean I don't think there's any
credible scientific source that says you
know sex is on a spectrum and so on and
so forth and intersex people kind of get
thrown under this bus the whole time
but the issue for intersex people is
that actually they have surgical
procedures practiced on them without
their choice and what they're saying is
actually could could we leave that to
later in life when we can make a choice
you know that seems to be a different
kind of issue so I think biology is is
is is I mean I don't like the phrase
science is settled because that's the
whole point about science you know but I
think we're pretty clear that we've had
thousands of years of a binary species
and and and I think that's probably sort
of where we reliably can uh we can rely
on well many people would think that's a
bigoted opinion but but okay but I think
yeah I would say I don't I would say we
would really agree I think most people
would be would be you know pretty clear
about that most people would recognize
that you know they were born of a woman
so the second thing I think then is to
say well what are our social
interactions
I have a friend called Jackie Gavin who
is a trans activist and a trans woman uh
she transitioned when she was in her 20s
I think
um
and Jackie's remarkable
she tells the story so I did a panel
with her once and I put this in the book
too which was that
she told her story she was called Scott
before she was Jackie
and somebody asked a question after she
told the story and they said um
I find this all really confusing and you
know misgendering dead now I don't know
what to do I feel really confused and
Jackie was fantastic he said to this
woman she's the first thing to do she
said just ask you know be open and ask
and be curious he said I and then she
said this extraordinary thing she said I
wouldn't be here if it wasn't for
Scott's bravery he's part of me and I
carry him everywhere I go and the
audience in front of her about 60 people
whatever just went
oh my God because what she'd said to
them was something they could absolutely
embrace it was her real it was her real
story and and it gave everybody a way in
and people afterwards could not stop
talking to it it was absolutely
beautiful so I feel that socially I I
mean I refer to Jackie as she now there
are a number of feminists and women who
will not do that I feel perfectly
comfortable to do that I also think
sometimes that it's just because I'm of
a generation of gay men that we used to
play around with gender like that you
know somebody would one of your friends
would have a fit and you go no she's
throwing her toys out of pram oh look at
her you know Etc so we're kind of used
to it but I'm fine with that and I refer
to Jackie several trans friends I would
easily refer to as she I don't have a
problem with that that's my social
interaction I find it more challenging
well it's people who haven't actually
transitioned and I find it more
challenging when it's people who are
very obviously male I mean there's
somebody who's on the trans Advisory
Group at Stonewall who published a video
and he sat there with a beard in a dress
saying that he's a lesbian and I say to
myself well I don't really think that's
I don't think that works really I'm
afraid I think that we're going to have
to find a different way of of referring
to that so I understand that the debate
and discussion and I'm open to that
discussion and I want to understand it
and I want to work our way through it
but that's a social thing and I think we
should be grown up enough all of us and
there will be people who will scream at
you for not doing it well that's just
the state of the world but actually
let's see if we can agree some
conventions some manners you know and
then you get to law and policy
and I think it's absolutely crucial that
Loris is based that we understand in law
that sex does matter in certain
circumstances that would be my starting
point and I think there's a very broad
range of people who agree with that the
question then comes what are the
implications of that and if you look at
sport well I do think that it's
absolutely reasonable if you trans
person you want to be in sport well you
you know that's great let's encourage
that but actually I think it's also fair
to say that if you have if it's a sport
that has a muscular advantage through
puberty then I think we have to think
about what category you then play in if
you look at equestrian sports for
instance
um men and women are not divided
if you think of show jumping and horse
racing they're not divided they they
race in the same category because
actually there isn't seen to be a
muscular there isn't a muscular
Advantage the the sort of something
happened in music this year which brings
a problem to that is that they got rid
at the Brit Awards they got rid of uh
male and female categories and then what
happened is that all for the best
artists whatever all the nominees were
men so obviously when it comes to
Creation there's no advantage that a
male or have as a well it's interesting
what led to that you see one of the
things I would ask is to say what led to
making those decisions who made those
decisions and what what did they have in
their mind when they were making those
decisions about what was the best artist
of that year another example similar to
that which is if you look at the ftse
100 and I I'm the first person to do
this counting and I did it ages ago
um there are more if you look at the top
300 jobs the ftse 100 there are more
white men called John David and through
there are in those top 300 jobs and
there are women or people who are not
white and I did this by literally
looking at and I mean literally
literally I don't be the teenage
literally I mean I actually did it I
looked at all the pictures and so I
might have made a mistake I accept that
but the margin is so huge and actually
there's a bit of an improvement which is
very exciting you have to add the
Michaels now to make it work so hurray
for progress
the question is the question is
why is that happening now you can point
your finger at it and say well you're
racist and sexist what actually is
happening if you research into it
is it's what the people making those
appointments value in the candidates
that they're appointing and what they're
valuing is what they've already got in
other words they see in the potential
candidates themselves and the skills
they bring so typically I've been on a
board before I've been an executive at a
footsie company Etc I would argue and I
have argued successfully with a number
of boards actually what you really will
give you a better board is looking at
what you've already got and then
thinking what can I add that's different
to give me that different discussion so
back to all my points about her
homogenous discussion your point about
if everybody's thinking the same
nobody's thinking what you do in a
really good board and really good
governance and really good risk
assessment is you disrupt a bit so you
have disruptors and that's what creates
the best board so what I'm saying is the
mechanism that creates that imbalance at
the top of the footsie is not out group
hostility it's not saying we don't have
women we're not having black people it's
to do with what people value and the
historical Pipeline and yes there is a
bit of saying oh women can't do this oh
show me the black Executives I would
deny that there's some there's very
likely some of that's going on but those
footsie companies it's all about profit
they have to make yeah but I'm sorry
keep on going back to this there's no
counterfactual
it is all about profit but how many
companies Crash and Burn because they
had HMV
crashed and burned because they didn't
realize the internet was on the way they
didn't have disruptors in their board
they were absolutely going down the tram
lines they thought they were selling CDs
they weren't they were selling content
and they failed to understand that so
all I'm saying is if you want to make
money have disruption have difference
but that comes from diversity of opinion
it comes from all sorts of diversity and
that's what I'm saying to you if you
look at Catherine Phillips's research
and you look at groups that are mixed in
all sorts of ways if they see and value
the difference and that can be ethnic
and it can be a mix of sexes it can be a
mix of all sorts of other things that
cognitive diversity is partly made up by
people's identity
I think I accept that that of course but
I'm honored I'm honored
oh I should go home happy now oh my God
Winston things
that's fantastic a well done me
I should put the big job done you're
actually doing something about it and
and uh your version of uh diversity and
is one I I do support and I do think uh
unlike that a lot of the Dei um
programs we're seeing which worry me
particularly as a severe waste of money
um yours is one that doesn't seem to be
falling into the same trapping so that's
very exciting and diversity by Design
if you're a CEO and you want a new way
through come and talk to Fanny
great well uh on that note Simon
Financial thank you so much for it's
been a real pleasure thank you your book
uh the power of difference you can where
can we get it Amazon absolutely
everywhere I think it's I think I think
it might be approximately 16 pounds 42.
approximately I think approximately
today great and more comedy yes I'm
going to do this show I've turned the
book into a show really and I think it's
so I want it to be interactive with the
audience and so I I when I run the
Perrier it was I basically I asked the
audience questions and and improvised
comedy I mean I'd written some stuff
before I'm not totally lazy but I'd
written some stuff before and then I
improvised at the audience so I want to
do the same really about current issues
so I think it's going to be called
Fanny's LGBT q a
laughs
you've got the names that's great so
infantual thank you so much for speaking
with me pleasure
[Music]